ein internationales forschungsteam hat
jetzt eine der größten strukturen
aufgespürt die jemals im zentrum der
milchstraße beobachtet worden
diese kosmische struktur erinnert von
ihrer form an eine sanduhr doch
tatsächlich handelt es sich wohl um zwei
gigantische blasen aus radiostrahlung
die fachleute schätzen dass dieses
gebilde rund sechs millionen jahre alt
ist doch wie ist es entstanden und wie
ist eben das forschungsteam auf die
schliche gekommen klick zum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das supermassereiche schwarze
loch mit der bezeichnung sagittarius
stern befindet sich im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
es ist wirklich ein schwerkraft gigant
doch im vergleich zu anderen schwarzen
löchern die sich in anderen galaxien
kern befinden ist anita llosa stern
inaktiv und ruhig doch jetzt hat ein
internationales forschungsteam zwei
gigantische blasen entdeckt die wie zwei
ballons oben und unten aus der galaxie
ebene herausragenden diese mysteriösen
kosmischen strukturen sind wirklich
riesig fachleute schätzen sie auf eine
größe von jeweils 700 lichtjahre die uhr
glas förmige struktur ist rund 450
lichtjahren dick und insgesamt 1400
lichtjahre hoch die beiden blasen
bestehen aus schnellen teilchen und
magnetfeldern in ihrem inneren bewegen
sich ionisierte gase mit rund 30
kilometern pro sekunde die radio blasen
zeichnen sich zudem durch klar
abgegrenzte und hell leuchtenden ränder
aus schätzungen zufolge könnte diese neu
entdeckte kosmische struktur eine
gesamtenergie von achtung rund sieben
mal 10 hoch 45 joule in sich tragen
das sind also 45 0 1 hinter der 7 die
entdeckung dieser kosmischen strukturen
gelangen dem forschungsteam mit hilfe
der merkt radioteleskope des south
african radioastronomie observatorio im
wellenlängenbereich um 23 zentimeter
nahmen die fachleute in die region rund
um st gitarrist stern genauer ins visier
und die aktuelle entdeckung ist wirklich
ein großer erfolg dazu fernando camilo
der an der studie beteiligt war
diese enormen bleibt
waren bisher von der extrem starken
radiostrahlung aus dem galaxien zentrum
überstrahlt sie aus dem hintergrund
heraus zu lösen war eine echte tour de
france eine weitere erkenntnis der
forschen ist dass diese neu entdeckten
blasen in derselben region liegen wie
die sogenannten fermi blasen dabei
handelt es sich um blasen aus schnellen
gasen und gammastrahlen die unglaubliche
50 tausend lichtjahre aus der galaxie
neben herausragen erst anfangen diesen
jahres konnte ein astronomie team
gigantische plasma schlote aufspüren die
womöglich das bindeglied zwischen den
galaxien zentrum und den fermi blasen
darstellen denn diese schornsteinen
transportieren energie kommen zentrum
hin zu dem blasen nun vermutet das
forschungsteam dass die neue
aufgespürten radio blasen quasi eine
schwächere variante der fermi blasen
darstellen könnten womöglich sind sie
nämlich auf ähnliche art und weise
entstanden und zwar durch einen früheren
ausbruch von sagittarius aussterben dazu
schreibt das autorenteam in der
aktuellen studie
wir sehen hier möglicherweise eine
weniger energiereiche version des
prozesses der auch die family blasen und
ihrer radiostrahlung smith wir sehen
damit eine neue manifestation der
enormen ausströmen von materie und
energie die vom zentralen schwarzen loch
ausgeben es gibt hinweise darauf dass
der letzte große ausbruch des zentralen
schwarzen lochs vor rund zwei millionen
jahren stattgefunden hat und auch in der
zeit davor war es wohl immer mal wieder
aktiv in solchen phasen hat das
gaswolken und sterne geschmeckt
vermutlich sind so auch die mysteriöse
radio blasen entstanden dazu der us
astronom william konnten die form und
symmetrie der blasen spricht sehr dafür
dass vor einigen millionen jahren ein
erschüttern starkes ereignis nach dem
zentralen schwarzen loch unserer galaxie
stattfand vermutlich ist dieser ausbruch
zumindest für eine kurze zeit in
entgegengesetzte richtung im
interstellaren raum abgelaufen was ich
da im zentrum unserer galaxie so
abspielt galaktischen giganten anklicken
anschauen und hyperraum tv abonnieren
cola kanal mit sehr sehr fundierten
videos bis dann bleibt dran